Elizabeth Branham is live for us in New
Delhi soil is what's been the reaction
to the government approving funding for
this population register folly we've
just returned from a rally at Delhi
University in the center of the capital
New Delhi and were joined now by one of
the speakers at that rally one of the
country's most prominent intellectuals
award-winning author Aaron that the Roy
miss Roy we saw you at the rally and I
know that you're very hopeful about this
moment in India now why is that why do
you think we are seeing the biggest
protest whether it's against the
citizenship law the National Register of
citizens were now the National
Population register that we've seen
against this government in the more than
five years that it's been in power well
I'm hopeful because this movement
intellectually understands and
emotionally and passionately understands
the horror of this Hindu to a program
that the Modi BJP RSS has been selling
for the last two many years and of
course in power since 2014 so they only
have this as the one answer to every
problem economic social education
whatever it is the idea is to write
their ideas to ratchet up the hatred you
know and suddenly young people are just
saying sorry but we're not buying this
you know and that's why I'm hopeful and
do you think that the protests that
we're seeing by young people by many
many people across the country will make
a difference because even as those
protests happened the government passed
funding for this National Population
register which many people see as a
precursor to the National Register of
citizens no it's it is a precursor it's
the data base you know so they are gonna
go through with whatever they can go
through it you know they're going to go
through with every bit of their agenda
and they're going to shed blood I mean
they already killing people all over the
state of uttar pradesh because that is
where they have the most vicious chief
minister acting in tandem with the
central government but they are losing
power in all the other states so
just a few years ago they were in power
in so many states separate states you
know in India now they just hold power
and I think three or four and ten chief
ministers have already said that they
will not allow the National Register of
citizenship they have not said that they
will not allow allow the NPR which is
the soft entry to this I think people
still have to understand that that's a
very dangerous thing but I I do think
that there's a chance if they ever were
the chance here is the chance to stop
them and do you think that the Supreme
Court will stop them when it hears
dozens of petitions against the
citizenship Amendment Act next month
look I don't know I don't have much hope
there you know because look at what
happened in that Sam you know they went
ahead with the National Register of
citizenship while the Supreme Court is
still hearing the case about whether or
not it's constitutional
you know so all the damage is already
being done and the Supreme Court is
still going along its plotting way and
the horror that's unleashed on people in
Assam because of this few people in
India know you know and so I'm just
hoping that it's going to have to take
much more than the supreme court the
supreme court has not stood in the way
of the government in any of its agenda
so far so I hope it will but I don't
have that much hope mr. Roy thank you so
much for your time so that is a
Arundhati Roy and we are expecting the
protests that we've seen over the last
two weeks to continue until at least
until the Supreme Court does hear those
petitions folly thank you very much for
that Elizabeth bharanam live for us in
New Delhi